how many did what your favorite all of
these is what your favorite moments
filming were and what your favorite
moment is in the actual final film wanna
keep my favorite moment of the whole
pretty now so many it was probably the
dancing sing to my birthday yeah
memories to my favorite scene was
probably the scene that I take that with
Jacob
Jenna Jake my second because it's
Jacqueline sort of turning point it's
where she could actually be rescued not
go out and see his friends he's they
were they were also come with it she
could have been saved at that point he's
a real gonna come back and flora and
girl so I actually got dialog home
defense against parties that was so fun
and I think I felt quite and empowered
being hidden and my face painted and
vanilla really cute costume Emily felt
like technically anonymous just seven
three yeah
so that play was to fill my future
monkey changed
I suppose it felt like Derek's here
today he's one thing would that discord
and there's been a one bit where we're
in Baileys cheese and Jacqueline and
it's gonna break we're rule was coming
up the stairs to go in the flat and
there's a really lovely channel like the
Derek please
at that point I'm kind of and from the
first day we heard that it kind of you
know you just brought some portion to me
that you know it's never gonna let me so
I think that's the one thing we someone
add something to your friends that
you've never you never imagined that
could happen something tell us a little
bit about the production design of the
folks it's fantastic I don't wonder if
you could talk Brian a little bit about
we're about to at filming taking
engineering is I'm talking about and and
how you manage to get the great looks
and so the interiors have actually three
different flats so there's kind of look
there excite one set of flats mrs.
Nichols corridor and kitchen was first
set flaps which we revisit lost
allocation of the first day and then we
did another set flaps up and half feel
that we went to which we were slated a
single flat we redressed it three times
but the production's later was same
sound Gary who was from Italy
she's more whereas our first row as well
we're thinking
really kind of got an idea of what we
want a straight away into the that great
job in terms of the different flats we
had we definitely for each of the main
the 3d women and the free flats we can
I'm designing the sale you know not set
rules but we blue the colors I like my
kind of gadgets always differently from
any computer game does but I you know
Leonard rate in the script a and
actually all of the balance of us albums
on no not gonna play us
they still think you don't have that you
know texture and feel those things I
think I know what was the best example
because if you if you write a note to
someone you choose what can appear where
you're gonna Raider on you choose what
kind of pain you're going to use you
choose how you're going to give it over
to them you know course if you write an
email it's kind of leash because you
know I wait an email exact same with
everyone else in here does where is Lee
that allows them to Shirley characters I
think you're also kind of I think he
also got helped to try and sure that
they can in some ways it's kind of a
comfort blanket for for Ely particularly
she's got all her little things in this
kennel that car we keep in the world
over there
so it's kind of partly I think
to kind of help kind of make these
characters a little bit more head
together
any other questions for the audience
tonight so if Brian and Claire went to
the same fancy dress party his pigments
what would you go out yes here we have
Jericho initial stages we have we
actually run this fundraising event
which is a good fundraiser party which
we lost money on but dressed up as being
wild and there is some picture somewhere
you will need to blackmail me
so that was originally just copy me look
ten times better than my almighty fake
animals their own profit but bigger
whale in it and don't keep so long King
that could be question great question by
the way any other questions in the
audience today first of all where
fantastic job I'm amazed how brilliant
the film was second leader Brian I guess
it was the first time you've done this
and you know they're a lot of challenges
and a lot that you had to deal with
limited budget and knowing everything
that you know now and if you had
unlimited Hollywood budget which he
would he change anything about the film
or would he think it's a part of what
made it almost perfect in the way it is
it's because it was a child in a fight
and he didn't have the budget and the
money thing that elective war same one
would be just a model that should say
something we basically have it one or
two takes on war scenes and a big thing
that we realized good editor was that
you can have set up the camera late for
a half an hour and then you get four
winners with the actors to do the scene
that then it's you know that's all the
time you have then you want to the next
one so I think I think you know having a
little bit more time would have been
useful to kind of have a bit more
variations between again
as a Fiat type if you're looking for
something that you don't have because
you only call levatino options welding
le saying all that the hit of issues
that we had with the phone or the hi-hat
with the film I guess are all things
that where they are in the original
scripts nothing you know think of
program or starve is kind of what you
need to put in a script and what are you
doing and I don't think you could really
teach someone that until they go through
the process of making a film anyone else
any more questions before we had last
chance
oh yes there is a gentleman right
towards the back I was very impressed
with the beginning of the film the
introduction there's wonderfully
wonderfully tell them very entertaining
a wonderful cartoonist
and also the thank you
I think there's an artist you don't know
that work call them human they bake and
she's like this a green artists who I
don't know how we find out
that one of the production department
Harry and I real late and every city of
them lots of family images of graphic
dolls I like and in particular the one
the sale of its kind of similar to
Iranian actors graphic novels call them
large islands of traffic and basically I
think I'm a typical Asian someone you
can call and that can style and
basically all the artwork in each room
and all those drawings we're done by the
same saying go and I think that when you
see them being gone I've had that was
married so I'm Marilyn visit land hated
the guardrail for so many learned how to
do them and any service
Haley was doing the jobs but they came
from the Dallas is that quite
challenging to do that jewelry married
how did you find it
well the graphic novel that were clearly
Pearlington
Louie - before the with the graphic
novel the anomaly I don't know if
everyone does this but Lee you cannot
get blue pants on you you draw the image
box then incorporate link and every new
force of copy the special blue pencil
isn't me wrong therefore to copy well
gonna finish off there by asking you
guys what you're gonna take away from
this film and I entirely something you
might learn that you're gonna take into
another project in future or just a
really memory or experience I'm not
gonna let any of that just just to keep
me entertained and ever made everyone
else it was a great six weeks it was six
weeks wasn't right but it was a great in
life of days I think to work these guys
even there to Brian's first film stuff
yeah that's what he was a real pleasure
to work with his director and so at
least you guys and you know I just take
away I can find on homers you know
people enjoy the film as much as I have
making I think my first feature is
Justin must've learned experience from
start to finish there's so many
buildings above other as well as
watching Telus guys so he said
Brian and so so much that could possibly
say yeah everything well my take on some
new projects what about you a couple of
things one to increase the Magnus effect
it had to be race it and all sort just
so much I have to learn just so much to
learn but also good things like learning
so and and I just hope I get the chance
to work with another director casting
crew that and to go into all their
energy into making something very
quality of what you see thank you Mary
I'd like it's like you becoming this
evening I hope you're getting you enjoy
it though I've seen some things you've
said tonight that you really have which
is fantastic and of course thanks to
these people here on stage two running
weeks - coffee - Mary Burke and - of
course our writer director Brian O'Neill
you